hello I'm true Joey I've been drinking
heavily and I'm gonna talk to you all
about the Reagan's Ronald Nancy and
others get ready
oh hi so it's 1949 a young actress named
Nancy Davis somehow gets on a communist
blacklist she knows I got it I gotta
talk to this president of the Screen
Actors Guild Ronald Reagan because he's
gonna help me he was in a movie called
knute rockne and he was in bedtime for
Bonzo a lot of people don't remember
Ronald Reagan was very liberal this is a
guy who's like hey I'm an actor I'm the
president of the Screen Actors Guild I
love my life I'm hot and pro-union and
all that stuff somebody said to Ronnie
like this actress Nancy Davis wants to
meet with you Ronnie so Nancy was like
she's hot
I'll make her thin that for dinner
outdoors
Nancy walks in and she is banging she's
like God it all happened it spelt a
spell to myself - any drinks
Julie glass is there any smaller small
lips we broke into this place oh no as
it is where are we during dinner and you
know she was like I'm on a blacklist of
the Communist Party he's like he was
like what and she was like yes can he
believe it he was like I can't he don't
seem like a communist to me and she's
like I'm not there was nothing communist
about her she was always
rabidly conservative he got to the
bottom of things and realize it was a
clerical error
so he got her off that list they were
like let's fall in love boom
Hollywood yeah Nancy follow I've had a
bottle of whiskey so tell me what you
want me to do I'll do whatever you want
me to do but I want I'm gonna make a
good show okay yeah yeah the Reagan's
we're married in 1952 Nancy you know
definitely convinced Ronnie where we are
husbands like we're not gonna make it in
Hollywood you need to be more
conservative okay
would you like that moon out how did you
stab your I am blah let's be famous you
know politically become the the faces of
conservatism she was basically like his
manager you need to be the movie star
that you are
always smile and holds her head to a
half 45-degree right angle I think she
in her mind ran her own studio and and
and she had one one player and that was
Ronald Reagan remember
business business
so it was 1964 Barry Goldwater was
running for president hyper conservative
a boring human being they employed
Ronald Reagan who was this famous great
actor to give the speech in the speech
he said you can either go right or left
but that's not what it is it's the up or
down and up you know you can choose to
up towards individualism or down and a
depth of totalitarianism people were
like wow I need to watch this
he has a chiseled jaw I trust him I like
this nine and said I can he got very
popular with the Republicans they were
not successful actors as actors but they
were incredibly successful actors as
politicians and Ronnie became the
Governor of California
Nancy was always about being famous on
any level like if I'm not gonna be a
movie star I'm gonna be you know in the
White House all of a sudden it's the
eighties he started to run for president
he made everyone feel good about about
being American again and Nancy coached
him Nancy was like talk about the
children
holidays talk about booze talk about all
that landslide one because they wanted a
hero she was charged she did it and it
was one grand performance until the end
what are we what are we talking about
right now just well hi everybody I just
burped on Comedy Central
[Music]